hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whack your boss - now
this might actually be made by the same
guy that made the original whack your
boss which is really cool
considering all the other whacking games
since then have been made by different
artists some good some not so good but
mostly pretty average but it's always
good to come back to the original and
this is whack your boss - fantasy
edition and there should be about 10
different ways for us to kill this
[ __ ] [ __ ] right oh no no no no
well what else you get the memo
no here's a fun fact huh memos are not
created to inform the recipient they're
designed to protect the sender so how
long have you been sitting there I have
no idea of 10 years in that time nothing
has changed except you've gotten weaker
I don't know what that did its Gant you
got teleported to another world or just
murdered I don't know how that works
oh jeez I don't know why that worked and
I don't know what was in your cabinet
that caused that to happen oh boy thanks
mister cleaner man hi boss good to see
ya no no no no no no no no didn't you
get the memo
not at all here's a fun fact [ __ ] memos
are not created to inform the recipient
they're designed to protect the sender
I'm gonna listen to all these cuz it was
oh how long have you been sitting there
over 10 years yeah in that time nothing
has changed except you've gotten weaker
and I've gotten stronger
having corporate mergers less government
restrictions governments that's a laugh
I know have the power to sue governments
they can't even protect their own
intellectual property aims I create
nothing new
ah and I'm proud of it yeah I simply sit
back and wait for someone else to create
something then I steal it
what's that I'm a parasite of course I
am
parasites are survivors and they will
outlive most species in the impending
mass extinction oh that depressing I
figured I want you and a depressed you
won't ask for anything even this cubicle
was designed to break you down by
separating you from your fellows whoa at
the same time it denies you the privacy
of a real office thus your cubicle takes
away your community and privacy zero
dignity you feel trapped alone powerless
have your doctor write you another
prescription
oh you wonder how I tolerate this place
here's a little secret I don't like
working here I love it
I thrive here I mask my low self-esteem
with corporate buzzwords like vibrant
robust core competency optics
stainability
that's a joke Wow stainable energy
projects will cost the company way too
much money the environment can wait Oh
polar bears are dying grizzly bears will
handle it as we speak
Grizzlies are moving north and mating
with the polar bears a whole new species
bees are dying too agave save the whales
clone the way to bait that around your
little water cooler enjoy that free cup
of water it could be your last
what you heard is true water is the new
oil the water wars aren't coming they're
already here okay oh man help our hero
click something in the cubicle man I was
having a great time listening to him and
I'm pretty sure some of that was
commentary on the other whacking games
in terms of stealing other people's work
anyway so alright hang on I gotta find
alright my own hand okay no one saw your
murder you're fine okay so something
about the original guy he displays is so
horrifying I mean there's been some like
bad ones since then but something about
the original the way they just like
deliberate these people these poor I
mean he's an [ __ ] obviously but my
goodness
okay nice ass alright wow I don't think
they're equipped with a hose I'm pretty
sure she eats the arms purpose I know
human anatomy and that's oh boy
there's a lot of light like more plugins
why are you not covered in blood
don't look at me I have a few questions
he could have spat it out at any time
there was enough enough a logic aside
man having people like blow up is one of
the worst ways I could possibly imagine
a death in like a movie or a game like I
still get nightmares okay bye peace Oh
what's not a dildo I mean it's it don't
know if you're brave enough I mean
wouldn't you want your last night to be
shoving a nuke up your butt no I don't
think you're cleaner how does it cleaner
gonna be I mean I know a lot of cleaners
but oh the other hand the back hand
oh man
the original is always best I suppose
how about the other drawer
oh no it is seitan well goodbye then
oh goodness gracious
awesome oh oh boy I love this I love it
there's nothing quite like the original
I gotta say nothing at all
hello let me just pull this out of my
well hello okay okay that's not normal
well it's bad that you were standing
exactly there are you prancing through
the mind you know that's not good pretty
good pretty good
fantasy edition for a reason I suppose
oh boy oh yeah the giant alien hands
from the sky perfect
oh well thanks for that this guy's just
like well I didn't plan any of that that
just happened holy [ __ ] well if I'm not
mistaken that's the end of whack your
boss too I mean the original my pizza
men's or lumbar oh good he's been
rescued is he gonna do it again as you
falling for the same trick punishment oh
man that was awesome
Tom Winkler who is probably the original
artist of all these games and a bunch of
other stuff too a lot of them poop
related I've checked them out there's a
lot of poop but either way thank you so
much for making this and thank you
everybody so much for watching us it's
awesome it's good to back get back to
the original I admit so thank you again
you can check out the other whacking
games in the description below or
through the annotations over there and
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
I would be scared to even though you
just murdered him and he probably
shouldn't be Wow